in late june footage from crypto mining
farms in china started popping up on
doyen
the chinese version of tiktok machines
that mine cryptocurrencies like bitcoin
were being dismantled and packed up
these facilities in china have produced
up to three quarters of the world's
supply of bitcoin
but that started to change when about a
month earlier one of china's most senior
officials said the central government
pledged to crack down
on bitcoin mining but he didn't specify
what measures it would take against
crypto miners
however some local authorities began
taking action
a government-backed news outlet showed
social media footage of miners turning
off machines after authorities in
sichuan province ordered electricity
providers to stop supplying power to
these facilities
all of this equipment came offline there
have been huge ripple effects
after beijing's warning the global
mining hash rate that's the measurement
of the computing power used to mine
bitcoins
dropped by almost 50 percent the sudden
drop just means everyone who continues
mining
now has a bigger piece of the pie so
miners around the world are taking
advantage of the exodus of chinese
miners to expand their own businesses
and hoping that the power behind
cryptocurrencies is becoming less
dependent on a single country
first you need to understand how crypto
miners make money bitcoin miners are
effectively participating in a global
lottery
every time they start mining bitcoin
brandon arvanaghi used to be a security
engineer at a crypto exchange and now
runs a company that helps miners set
up facilities miners are solving these
complex math problems that secures the
bitcoin network
what these mining farms do is they're
able to do things in bulk
if we do it at scale the odds are that
we'll
eventually win the lottery so crypto
mining farms are usually made up of
thousands of specialized computers
and the miners who get the right answers
first are rewarded with new
cryptocurrencies
and these new coins can be then sold
onto exchanges
the vast majority of these specialized
machines have been manufactured in china
giving miners their quicker and cheaper
access than others around the world
these computers are consuming a lot of
electricity it was so appealing to mine
in china because of the almost
free power from these hydro plants for
example so with easy access to both
machines and power
a large share of global bitcoin mining
has happened in china
the beijing's tightening grip on the
industry is forcing its homegrown miners
to look for a way out
since 2017 crypto trading has been
outlawed in china because of the
potential risks cryptocurrencies pose to
financial stability
and the possibility of the assets being
used for illegal activities
and now mining has come into sharper
focus because of the massive amount of
electricity consumed by farms
posing a threat to beijing's commitment
to limit its carbon footprint
so miners in china are selling their
machines overseas or moving their
operations to countries like the us
russia and kazakhstan this exodus from
china has benefited miners elsewhere
we are immediately earning more bitcoins
every day
ben gagnon is a chief mining officer at
bid farms a publicly traded bitcoin
mining company in canada
and he says business after beijing's
announcement has been booming
it is still kind of hard to believe that
all of this equipment came offline
as that market share and the hash rate
has been cut in half
our share of the bitcoin revenues has
effectively doubled
this has also meant access to some of
the best machines that were once hard to
get
all the machines that are being
manufactured and are contracted to these
chinese customers
that no longer have a place to be
installed prices of these mining
machines have also dropped substantially
for instance one of the most popular
models which used to cost more than ten
thousand dollars was available for
around half the price
with the market awash and cheat machines
gannon says crypto miners are looking to
expand across north america and central
asia
all around the world i think people are
excited they're looking to gain that
market share and and
either you can work with chinese miners
or to purchase their equipment from them
and earn that revenue for themselves but
expansion comes with one big item that
isn't so easy to come by
now the bottleneck is really on power so
if you buy these machines and you don't
have a place to plug them in
it's not really a good use of your
investment gadnon says it's a race
against time to set up the power
infrastructure before other miners come
back online
because it just takes a lot longer to
develop this infrastructure outside of
china
a lot of groups are doing what we're
doing right now and they're focusing on
the energy infrastructure they need to
negotiate it they need to secure the
permit so
it's a long path forward but the crypto
industry overseas could face similar
pressures as in china
for instance in the u.s authorities have
proposed plans to hold crypto exchanges
to the same standards
as traditional securities and financial
services while some local communities
have expressed concerns about the
environmental impact of mining
facilities
despite the challenges ahead once these
new mining farms are created
crypto mining will likely no longer be
concentrated in just one place
concentration in china is the most
dangerous outcome
because as you can see the entire mining
industry in that state can shut down
as for china's homegrown miners the once
golden place for mining will become a
less viable option
these miners in china are now looking
for new homes in favor of places that
are secure
they know the costs are far too high
they need stability